triunfo contundente del equipo de los
tres leones contra senegal por 3 a 0 en
un partido que no empezó bien Eso sí
para el combinado europeo que sufrió en
los primeros compases en la primera
puerta con una senegal que estaba
dominando y que llegó a atacar con
peligro Y de qué manera la portaría de
Jordan pickford el portero británico que
fue un héroe para los británicos en la
primera media hora con una ocasión que
tuvo día esta ocasión para los
senegaleses fue un llamado de atención
para los británicos que para el minuto
38 se adelantaron por mediación de
Jordan Henderson quien culminó la
perfección una jugada colectiva del
equipo de Inglaterra Harry kane que
metió un pase en profundidad para
el jugador del Borussia dortmo que
asistió de manera brillante para
Henderson quienes Solo que mejor sabe
hacer que es llegar en segunda línea
antes del Descanso llegó el dos a cero
que lo hizo esta vez Harry kane quien no
había marcado todavía en esta copa mundo
culminando de nuevo una bonita jugada
que protagonizó yuxelingham
transportando la pelota durante unos 30
metros para luego pasar a foden y este
fue finalmente el que existió para el
capitán para la segunda parte del tanto
definitivo del tres a cero lo puso
bocayo saca quien fue titular en este
encuentro en reemplazo de Marcos rasford
bucayos saca una de las mejores figuras
del partido junto con joselingham
increíble lo de yus tiene apenas 19 años
seguramente lo veremos pasar muy pronto
del dorman para algún equipo de la
Premier League lo quiere el Manchester
City lo quiere United lo quiere el
Liverpool Harry kane también hizo un
gran despliegue en este partido con el
que los británicos se plantan en cuartos
de final para un duelo estelar contra
Francia dos equipos con una rivalidad
histórica enorme la última vez que se
enfrentaron por una copa mundo fue en la
copa mundo de España en 1982 con triunfo
en ese entonces para los británicos por
tres a uno